Y la epidemia de opioides no ha hecho más que profundizar ese problema.
Cuando en 2013 fui contratada por la Biblioteca Gratuita,
tomé la decisión de trabajar específicamente en McPherson
porque sé lo que es criarse en un contexto
donde los trastornos por consumo de drogas afectan la vida diaria
y quise usar mi experiencia personal
como guía de mi trabajo.
Pero antes de referirme a eso,
les contaré cómo fue
ser testigo del crecimiento de esta epidemia en Kensington.
Al igual que muchas comunidades, simplemente no estábamos preparados.
Empezamos por observar los documentos de identidad:
los domicilios establecidos en condados vecinos y del norte
y luego los establecidos fuera del estado.
Gente de Arkansas, Ohio, Carolina del Sur y Alabama
venía a Filadelfia para conseguir heroína a bajo precio.
Muchos empezaron a demorarse cada vez más tiempo
en nuestro baño público,
lo cual hizo que prestáramos más atención al baño
que a nuestras responsabilidades diarias,
porque el baño era un sitio accesible para consumir la droga recién comprada.
En una oportunidad, los inodoros se atascaron de tal manera
que debimos cerrar la biblioteca durante dos días
por la obstrucción que causaron las agujas desechadas.
Antes de aquel incidente, veníamos insistiendo
en la colocación de recipientes para objetos punzantes en el baño.
Y después de ese episodio,
la administración del lugar dio la inmediata aprobación para instalar uno
y contrató vigilantes dentro el baño.
A medida que los días se ponían más cálidos,
nuestro trabajo se multiplicaba.
Empezaron a acampar en el parque durante días, o semanas.
Si uno salía a caminar en un día cálido y soleado,
se encontraba con gran cantidad de personas
en distintos grados de intoxicación
y niños jugando entre ellas.
La cantidad de agujas que Teddy recogía por mes
trepó de 100 a 300, luego a 500, luego a 800,
hasta superar las 1000 agujas,
muchas de ellas tiradas en las escalinatas de ingreso
o en el sector de juegos infantiles.
Luego ocurrieron los casos de sobredosis.
Muchos sucedían afuera, en el parque;
otros, dentro de la biblioteca.
Sterling, el guardia, se pasaba el tiempo entrando y saliendo del edificio,
recorriendo el parque, para asegurarse de que nadie corriera peligro,
porque en ciertos casos
temíamos que alguien muriera de sobredosis allí mismo.
Tuvimos un caso de sobredosis después de la escuela.
La biblioteca estaba llena de niños, bullicio y desorden.
Y en ese momento,
se oyó un golpe seco que provenía del baño público.
Cuando abrimos la puerta, había un hombre en el piso, inconsciente.
Lo retiraron a la vista de todos,
de niños, adolescentes, adultos, familias.
Un empleado llamó al 911,
otro llevó a los niños y adolescentes al piso inferior,
alguien fue al parque a esperar la ambulancia
y el resto de los que allí estábamos
simplemente nos quedamos esperando.
Fue como un entrenamiento en caso de sobredosis,
porque en ese momento era todo lo que podíamos hacer.
Durante la espera, veíamos a este hombre perder la respiración,
casi paralizado.
Se estaba muriendo.
No sé si han presenciado alguna vez una persona con sobredosis de opioides,
pero es espantoso,
porque uno sabe que la dificultad respiratoria,
la pérdida de color en el rostro
son la cuenta regresiva en sus posibilidades de supervivencia.
Pero afortunadamente,
la ambulancia llegó y le inyectaron una dosis de naloxona.
Recuerdo que el hombre se sacudió como si lo estuviesen electrocutando,
se quitó la aguja
y pidió a los paramédicos que lo dejaran en paz.
Se puso de pie y se marchó.
Y nosotros
regresamos al trabajo,
porque había gente que nos pedía ayuda con las computadoras,
niños que necesitaban apoyo con sus tareas escolares,
y ese era nuestro trabajo,
nuestra función.
Creo que recuerdo tan bien aquel incidente por el tiempo de espera.
Me produjo impotencia.
Y fue ese sentimiento de impotencia lo que me recordó mi niñez.
Antes de que yo naciera, mis padres comenzaron a consumir heroína,
lo cual tornó nuestra vida caótica e inestable:
promesas que nunca se cumplían,
discusiones, el peso del secreto entre ellos,
el peso de nuestro secreto excluía todo lo "normal" de nuestras vidas.
Cada vez que nos dejaban en casa de mis abuelos,
me asaltaba el pensamiento de que nunca los volvería a ver.
Cada vez que nos dejaban en un auto, una casa o una tienda, yo lloraba.
Y cada vez que veía esas vías del tren,
las mismas que hoy uso para ir a trabajar a McPherson,
desde el asiento trasero del auto,
me enojaba,
porque aun los niños se dan cuenta
cuando sus padres tratan de comprar droga.
Era tan poco lo que yo podía hacer
para controlar lo que ocurría a mi alrededor
que esa sensación de impotencia era agobiante.
Era un esfuerzo ir a la escuela, me costaba leer,
tenía tendencia a la ira y la depresión.
A los 11 años empecé a fumar,
y de allí pasé a experimentar con las drogas y el alcohol.
Estaba convencida de que el pasado de mis padres sería mi futuro.
Pero con el tiempo, ellos se recuperaron
y no recayeron en el consumo de opioides.
La fortaleza y el compromiso que demostraron
nos dieron sostén y estabilidad, a mí y a mis hermanos,
y fueron esas experiencias personales las que me trajeron a McPherson.
La decisión de trabajar como bibliotecaria
y de formar parte de McPherson
me permitió liberar esa sensación de impotencia
y de encontrar la forma de ayudar a otros.
Y una manera de brindar apoyo fue aprender a administrar Narcán.
Las bibliotecas públicas responden a las necesidades de sus comunidades,
y si no saben utilizar Narcán no pueden dar ese servicio de ayuda.
Estábamos en el frente de batalla
y necesitábamos imperiosamente acceder a esta herramienta
para salvar vidas.
Finalmente, a fines de febrero de 2017,
luego de mucho insistir,
recibimos capacitación del programa 'Prevention Point Philadelphia'
y al cabo de aproximadamente un mes,
usé Narcán por primera vez para salvar la vida de una persona.
De nuevo, fue después de la escuela.
Teddy entró a la biblioteca
y avisó que alguien estaba con una sobredosis en el parque.
De nuevo, un empleado llamó al 911
y yo recurrí al kit de Narcán.
La joven tenía apenas 20 y tantos años, y casi no podía respirar.
La amiga le palmeaba el rostro una y otra vez
con la esperanza de revivirla.
Le apliqué Narcán por vía nasal
y por fortuna reaccionó.
Pero antes de que la ambulancia llegara,
ella y la amiga se marcharon corriendo.
Cuando me di vuelta,
vi a los niños.
Niños que visitan la biblioteca a diario,
algunos de los cuales conozco desde hace años,
parados en las escalinatas del edificio.
Y lo vieron todo.
Pero no se los notaba afligidos ni conmocionados.
En ese momento entré,
fui a la sala de trabajo y rompí en llanto.
Lloré en parte por la conmoción de lo que acababa de ocurrir,
porque nunca imaginé que salvaría una vida,
pero lloré más que nada por esos niños.
Ellos viven esto como algo normal.
Esto es normal en la comunidad.
Esta es una normalidad catastrófica,
y en ese momento
debí enfrentar nuevamente la realidad de que esto nunca debía ser lo normal.
Y como ocurrió en mi niñez,
cuando uno está adentro, lo acepta sin más.
La epidemia de opioides no afecta tan solo
a quienes padecen de trastornos por el consumo,
pues el alcance de la epidemia trasciende al consumidor
y a sus familias.
Afecta a toda la comunidad.
Kensington era una comunidad en crisis antes de esto
por razones que son endémicas y están entrelazadas,
y quien conozca el barrio puede decir por qué:
diferencias raciales,
inoperancia del gobierno local y federal
para destinar fondos suficientes a las escuelas,
falta de recursos económicos.
Lo que intentamos hacer en McPherson
es buscar la manera de ayudar a esta comunidad a salir de la crisis.
Y quizá ahora, gracias a la epidemia,
se esté prestando más atención a Kensington.
Pero independientemente de eso,
en McPherson,
seguiremos haciendo lo posible con los recursos que tenemos
y seguiremos brindando todo el apoyo necesario
para mantener la seguridad y la salud de la comunidad,
porque las bibliotecas públicas
siempre fueron más que una mera colección de libros.
Somos un refugio físico,
un aula,
un puerto seguro,
un comedor,
un centro de recursos
y sí...
también una tabla de salvación.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)